they've let us start with number three
one six and Then followed by two five
eight
is this an auction
ball
Mark Williams here in the back uh to
your
to your left a little bit there you are
right yeah from below the line and
Beauty cinematographer so we talked a
little bit of independent Spirits about
timelines and multiverses and you talked
about trying to keep all of that in
order and reaching out for some help to
do that can you expand on that tonight
how you how you captured all this
journey and wrangled into making sense
for us as an audience as an editor yeah
I mean I really just I use the crutch
that is uh Michelle really
um and her her ability to
translate this insane script into
emotion into a an emotional Journey so
at any point I just would would focus on
her and you know I also had Dan and
Daniel by my side and they you know this
they've been working on this film for
five six years so
they knew exactly what they wanted and
they were also just really excited to be
surprised and really excited to to
explore it in a new way in the edit and
so that was the a really wonderful
experience
full all right we have two five eight
followed by two seven two
hi there uh John Boone from A-frame uh
you said on stage this is your second
film how do you feel like this process
and this experience has changed you as
an editor as you head into whatever
comes next I hope it doesn't change me
too much I feel like I have a pretty
healthy blend of like
insecurity and confidence and like need
to prove myself and also disregard for
what other people think and and if
they'll get out of whack then I'm
screwed and so this is a really bad
thing for me and I need I need to be
brought back down to Earth because the
insecurity is such a kind of honestly
important part of the way I work which
is like uh the fear of failing my
friends my directors the actors I felt
an enormous responsibility to Michelle
and key especially because they had been
you know kind of treated so wrong by all
of us uh for so long and I was so
grateful to be
um
given the responsibility of helping tell
a part of their story and uh and so
that's what I'm in on stage when I said
I hope I did right by by you both and by
the whole cast because I felt um
you know it's
they did an incredible Thing by sticking
it out and by not giving up and uh I'm
just really honored and humbled to have
been able to be a part of that
okay we have 272 followed by a question
from our virtual Press Room
oh hey Tina how you doing how are you
good congratulations thank you
um yesterday at iava you talked about
how your journey with the Daniels
started at a roller rank so with that
context would you talk about just you
know reflect on your journey with them
and you know culminating with tonight
yeah uh
they're my friends
first before everything and um I care
really deeply about them and
you know no matter what happens this
movie really felt like an excuse to just
spend time with people that I cared
about and uh Dan and Daniel two people
that I care really deeply about and they
also they allowed us to make this film
in a really humane way
you know reasonable hours time with our
family
no yelling no screaming no you know
fights it was all just let's love each
other and let's make a great film to
help the world and um and I I've been
trying to take that forward with me to
every project I do you know there's a
problem in our industry that the more
you kill yourself for a movie The braver
you are and that's you know we
can all we can make up films and we can
in everyone's job we can do our jobs and
we can live our lives and the more fully
we are able to live our lives and the
more humanely we treat ourselves and the
people around us the better we can do
our jobs and uh and they were really
that starts at the top with them so yeah
I really I really value that in them
thank you
oh sorry friendly reminder to refrain
from broadcasting or taking telephone
calls while we're in the middle of
interviews
um and now for the virtual Press Room we
will be taking a question from the wrap
hello Paul can you hear me yeah I got
you it's it's Joe McGovern from the rap
congratulations thank you
so it's it's incredibly rare for a
comedy to win this category I think the
last one was Who Framed Roger Rabbit 35
years ago
uh maybe I can get a fact check on that
but um
I think it's true and can you talk about
maybe some pride you might feel about
that piece of trivia but also how
important it is as an Editor to make
sure that all of the comedic beats I
mean it's a you know it's more than just
a comedy obviously but the absurdism
um how important it is for you in your
job to make sure that all that stuff
lands right yeah I think um you know I
kind of cut my teeth at absolutely
Productions which is Tim and Eric's
company working on the Eric Andre show
and the editors there are to me Geniuses
of comedy and Luke Lynch was a really
influential Editor to me who taught me
everything I know about editing comedy
and the the key with this film I think
is that what Dana Daniel are really good
at is taking something silly and
treating it very seriously and um and
that tends to lend itself to the comedy
I never thought of this as a comedy they
never pitched it to me as a comedy they
pitched it to me as a story about a a
mother and a daughter and a family and
so we treated it as seriously as that
and and the humor you know flows out of
it the way that it does in in life you
know and some of the darkest times in
our lives you know we we find these
moments to laugh with each other
especially when we're with family
because we know that there's a deeper
connection there and that even if things
are tough that sometimes the humor is
what brings us together so that's how we
try to treat it just as seriously as we
could I don't know any you know
about the history of the Oscars I think
it's as far as in terms of you know the
last comedy to win but um but in my mind
this isn't a comedy it's a family it's
just a story of a family
okay next up we have three eight five
right here in the center of the room
followed by three three eight
hey Paul it's Jasmine yeah hey again
congratulations thank you you said being
nominated was very strange a while ago
like how does it feel to win tonight and
talk a little bit about the alternate
ending that you that could have been
because the original cut was two hours
45 minutes yeah it's it's less of an
alternate ending and there was a scene
towards the end where they all you know
everyone come to comes together and
sings Barbie girl which I'm kind of
wondering if we'll all do tonight
um because they've you know we all use
our extra tickets to bring as many crew
members as we could so I think there's
like 60 crew members here which is why
everyone's applaud's so big you know
whenever any the the movie comes up
um but yeah I it's wonderful it's
incredible to to win and and one of the
things that I wish I had mentioned on
stage was that I one of the honors of
this experience and one of the great
things that the academy does and Ace and
and the guild is they bring all the
editors together so getting to spend
time with the other nominees was
a real honor because they are so
incredibly talented
um so yeah it was it was wonderful
cool okay okay next we have three three
six
sorry three three eight
hi
that's you yeah
hello congratulations thank you on on
the Oscar and uh obviously everything
ever all at once made enormous history
tonight with so many awards such a great
film and my name is Nicola Morales so I
forgot to say that it's a long night
cultural Focus Magazine but what do you
think is
um from your perspective the magic
behind the film that made it such an
important film with so many important
themes like representation diversity
immigration and so forth I mean there's
a lot if if we dive into the film but
specifically what is the magic what is
that it's a great question because we
as we were cutting it and I think even
as a writing and shooting it they knew
that there was some magic there but it
was hard to figure out what exactly it
was there's so much in this film
um but in general I think it's just
people telling a good story it's as
simple as that you know I think
people
you know we see a lot of movies that
that tell
um stories about certain types of people
right and they tend to focus on uh
kind of the story of the man the story
of the white man and and having this
beautiful story of an immigrant family
um was amazing and I think it's just for
you know like uh James Hong was
describing in his speech uh it's just
it's long long long overdue and like you
know this kind of thing
unfortunately does happen to guys like
me a lot too much most of the time and
so I think that we what Dan and Daniel
are really conscious of is paying
attention to who are we mentoring who
are we hiring uh how are we what kind of
stories are we lending our our time and
our energy to tell
and that's in them you know
I don't know if that's the one if
there's one thing that is the magic to
this film but that's part of it I think
it's a combination of good people making
good films with other good people uh and
telling good stories so yeah
and a great cast yeah Michelle and key
were incredible
uh Stephanie Shu was just insane
and Jamie and James and everybody tally
who plays Becky who by the way her her
cat her name the movie is Becky stregor
which is Rogers backwards she's named
after my wife Becky Rogers
so I made sure to give her a lot of
screen time
wonderful thank you so much and
congratulations thank you
[Applause]